hey guys Ryan right over here I can't
believe I'm gonna say this I say a lot
of things on this channel but I know
religions a very touchy subject [ __ ] me
in the ass cuz I love Jesus I've gotten
one too many requests to check out this
video here we go
Oh God
yeah it's true
god
all my life I've been good do what my
mom and dad and God say I should go to
church and Bible school to live by God
so whatever people tell me other girls I
got my girls in check
it was easy to do till I've got a
boyfriend and hurting my friends but
he's he does but I made a pact to keep
my hymen intact and Jesus and I are
tight guys can't wait that long
I don't want to lose him to someone
who'd do it
[Music]
thank you for giving me posted choose
from and since I'm not a godless [ __ ]
they'll have to come in the back door
therefore [ __ ] me in the ass cuz I love
Jesus the Lord won it that way give me
that sweet sensation of a sobbing
rationalization because everyone knows
it's a sex but God can't see it's hard
[Music]
shove it in my ass [ __ ] me until you
come oops
I mean let's join our souls and unite
our bodies in private the wings of
written Satan's doorbell God can't
ignore this and no prophylactics when
Cody Damian controls for [ __ ] and it's
a sin at empty my bowels and laid out
the towels I'm ready for romance now I'm
crazy power that's the highest but if
all of my poles this one is the Christ
and we can't procreate
if the Annalee copulate and gods okay
the sodomy but only if you're straight
and I'm staying here no matter what
so I'm ok with everything but and I
think something yes I love Jesus
the good Lord wanted that way give me
that sweet sensation of the rock
commercialization it's just between you
and me everyone knows it's the sex God
can't see oh my god it's still ago
because they're unrealistic it the best
silent but for sure so let's not talk
about how the good book and shellfish
polyester and divorce and how condemn
slavery and feeling gay is thus those
parts don't have of course let's Jerry
pick the part about losing my cherry
invited her ambiguities and emissions to
circumvent any real sacrifice but still
new pie's my arbitrary
positions and don't you dare question my
convictions and don't look closely at
the contradictions just focus on the
sacrificial crucifixion and have faith
its complete jurisdiction is the only
way to measure if you're good or not
I've been a debate just say to half
because with up against logic it's the
only card
[Music]
[Music]
yeah my chastity belt has locks but
sometimes you need to think outside
I once posted a video on this channel
that I took down cuz it was pissing off
way too many people called Jesus and the
Easter Bunny it was the story of Jesus
and the Easter Bunny's origins and how
they actually connect that was a
straight-up fictional tale I know
there's gonna be people in the call box
were like it's not that bad I don't get
what the big deal is I'll give a [ __ ]
what you say that's some of the most
offensive [ __ ] I've seen in a long time
oh man it's kind of inspiring you can't
really argue with what they're saying
like I grew up Catholic for most of my
life I with I can say I was primarily
Catholic I knew the religion in and out
and seeing this video I'm like yeah I
know that there's actually some good
points that they're making and I love
how it's making fun of these people you
know there are some attacks that are
just like on the Bible pretty much but
it's mainly attacking those people who
are like I can get away with anal sex
because it's not in my [ __ ] and I can't
get pregnant from it I'll have you know
that anal sex it's so much easier to get
an infection that way and you could
damage a nerve where you have internal
bleeding but it's so worth it if you
ever do it it's so awesome one thing I
really love our female comedians who are
willing to go all out and these two
women I love their level of commitment
to the escalation of how worse it got to
the point where that are getting plugged
in the ass and they're still seeing I
really admire them and
temperatures going all out like that and
same thing with the lyrics of the song
it's like you can't help it it's very
[ __ ] offensive but it's kind of
catchy at the same time anyway guys
thank you for telling me that was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
where it's so much fun on there you know
reading what we write pictures we post
it's really about getting likes and
favorites and retweets you know it's
more about that than anything else we
like attention finding Molly finding
molly recently follow us on instagram i
usually like 98% of the time we'll take
the shout outs from the facebook.com
slash real reject shout out page but
finding Molly saw she followed some
Instagram says she loves the channel and
I saw her photos she lives in England so
I can say this she's really cute
you all one love little enlighting you
all beautiful I am what we sweeping over
chimney all where our well if you know
online sweep your chimney if you know
what I mine
[ __ ] me in the ass cuz all of chasers